[Music]
all right uh Ryan's not here if you guys
didn't get it I just pressed record on
that I hope you're in focus I hope
you're in focus because right now I'm
not focused as you can see get a lot of
stuff going on here I'm alone in the
house I do have my dogs but you know I
don't think I combed my hair this
morning I did shower I've got like some
loafers on no socks I don't know what
the hell's going on you're listening to
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum
didn't even say that to open it up
unless Ryan just switched it crazy times
but everybody's talking about it and
there's just let's not be redundant
let's just get into it huh
this is just what it is this is well how
we're living I suggest we all have a
routine because right now my routines
effed and I notice a big difference in
my attitude my mindset if I don't wake
up and have something to do motivated to
do something working out or walking or
reading or writing or something from
[ __ ] you understand me
I'm effed let's not use the f-bomb let's
try not to use the f-bomb but I'm
excited to be here I'm excited that I
can go in this room and you start
talking and hopefully someone's
listening and you are listening I want
to thank all of you for subscribing and
listening to inside of you a lot of you
since the beginning
and I just you know I miss Ryan hi Ryan
one day you'll be back here but for now
I'll just pretend you're Wilson the ball
from castaway but you know please
subscribe on YouTube we are now filming
all of them we put a lot of cash into it
Ryan's busting his ass editing them
which is not easy and we're giving it to
you so you got the video to watch make
sure you subscribe push the little bell
to notify you every week so you could
watch the episodes and you know some of
you aren't working some of you are so
continue to listen to an audio Spotify
Apple whatever you're listening to I
appreciate the hell out of you I really
do and my patrons I can't say enough
I've been doing these live instagrams
insta lives I've been doing the Facebook
lives I'm not doing the tic-tock I just
can't get into it I don't know maybe one
day I just can't just it's too
overwhelming for me I just don't get it
I don't need to make a 15-second funny
video somebody goes oh my god it was
funny and just why I mean just too much
I think it's happy there's there's so
many things it's like people are just
not connecting at all so I think that's
part of the this this this show I just
want to connect I want to connect to you
I want to connect to people and I want
to talk about stuff hopefully that you
or someone out there can relate to and
you know it's weird like not being able
to do any conventions
you're just you're quarantined right I
mean if you're if you're playing by the
rules if you're doing if you you know
we're actually saving lives
inadvertently I think by doing that but
so thank you guys for for listening
patreon I'm on the Cammie L if you want
a Cammie and those are fun but also
remember to there's a lot of homeless
people by the way that needs your help
more than anything food on foot org
really helps I know Bob Odenkirk he he's
part of that organization I'm part of
the organization I'm a club member
Ronald McDonald House their families
need need food need meals I've done some
meals for them and you can too so
contact ronal mcdonald house wherever
you are across the nation and help them
out because it sucks can't volunteer
right we can't be in person so we have
to
in fact I have all these pizzas
delivered and now they have to have them
delivered piece by piece like when they
deliver it they have to put each each
piece in a ziploc bag or whatever
separated also things are complicated
and that's the phone all my love by the
way to throughout dancing she
talk to rob Danson real quick I mean we
don't have Rob here did I'm trash I'm
trying to record right now for my
podcast I'm literally recording so
you're on the air what do you got buddy
are yourself so Wow couple pull-ups
could cost you some big-time hard time
[Music]
masturbating well whether there's a
pandemic or not masturbating is
essential for mental health I agree with
you this is Rob Danson by the way he's
the guitarist and left on Laurel he's my
guitarist and now we're doing some stuff
on her own that we're rocking out too so
anyway Rob alright buddy alright stay
healthy buddy I was robbed Danson nice
guest that popped up like that you know
maybe we could do a little intro with
Stephen Amell no I don't know yeah
that's actually fun just a little I
wonder that might be a good thing they
do call a special guest in the intro of
every episode just to say hey and a
little 30-second minute-to-minute thing
just going how you doing how you holding
up they don't have to be here they could
just be on FaceTime and you could see
them that would be pretty cool kind of
add to the show what do you guys think
about that right in tell me patrons I
know you will and anyway let's thank you
for the support thank you for the love
Zach Levi if everything goes right and
the world comes back together we'll be
in Austin July 2nd at the north door
back-to-back shows live podcast get your
tickets
but that will happen sometime we're
gonna get back to normal but right now
let's get but let's get to abnormal with
my good buddy
let's get inside of Nick Swardson it's
my point of view you're listening to
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience did why is it that this is the
first time I'm seeing you since since
you have been gone since I think uh um I
don't know is it before the summer I was
gone all summer then I went to the
hospital and then I came back and then I
was away for the holiday so yeah I guess
it's been a minute hasn't yeah we uh I
think it doesn't feel like it's the last
time I saw you I think I I couldn't been
when I did your uh your show
typical wreck no I saw you after that I
did the podcasts after that that was
that long ago uh yeah thinking she did a
podcast my podcast probably a year and a
half ago when I started that yeah we did
it first yeah
what is RVCA on your handstand it's Ruka
it's a company out of why do they give
you money no I just I like their stuff
it's pretty comfortable and so but you
know it's very nice there's so much I
want to say God
hold it I mean you don't talk about on
the podcast why not
I think it's I'm joking it's the only
time to talk about sorry I know I just
think it's important man it's just like
you know you're somebody who's got you
know there's so much success so much you
already looked at your watch did you
just look at your watch two three
seconds and I move this to get more
comfortable to hear the nice things you
were saying well you are you're an
extraordinary talented guy looks at his
watch again okay I didn't I didn't the
first time but you are you're you're
funny I was watching some of your
stand-up again cuz I've done stand-up
with you have watched you do stand-up
I've watched you just you're one of
those guys who you seem like you're
fearless but there's there's still you
know you hide it well well I think
you've hidden your fear in a lot of ways
maybe through alcohol maybe through
through over the years is this how you
talk now is this like the new Mike no
this is all man this is an old Mike I
need to get new one god no man I was
just thinking like all these things like
that I psychoanalyze my diarrhea Joe no
but look I know a lot of [ __ ] happen and
the reason why I thought it was like
isn't it really talking about diarrhea
yeah here's a nick swardson line I'd
rather eat cold food fast and not get a
brain freeze or eat hot spicy food and
not get fired butthole mm-hmm yes that's
correct I'm 43 years old
these are the things that I talk about
you still eat fast food
I don't eat fast food that much I do
every once in a while but I've always
liked ate really healthy even when I was
at the peak of my drinking just
completely insanity like I would be just
chugging vodka and I'd be like yeah can
I get a salad yeah and then yeah five
shots of fireball thank you thank you
is that true yeah I would do it all the
time do you have tofu with that does
that go good with the Jagermeister okay
perfect perfect thank you think he's
joking Ryan this isn't a joke no I
literally I'll do it all the time and
people would be like what the [ __ ] and I
would always take I was this real like
extreme dichotomy of
I would I would just when I drank it was
I mean and I had a blast I love drinking
and then I but I would always take
vitamins I have all this stuff that I
would do and people be like why and I
would take all that all this stuff maybe
that helped you get through all that at
that time I think it definitely
maintained me for a point for people
that don't know I quit drinking four
months ago I mean yeah is that the
longer she quit drinking no I've quit
for a while and so I mean I've quit I
would drink like half the year and I
wouldn't drink while I was filming some
movies I did what movies that were you
drunk on I was never like drunk but if I
had a couple days off but we would go
drinking you know what I mean me in the
cast and I mean but I you learn too you
know and you know this is an actor um
like what the older you get the more the
drinking really shows up when you're in
your 20s you can go get drunk and show
up be like uh and you can you don't look
like it but like when when you get into
your 30s and then 40s it's like oh and I
remember the first time I noticed that I
went out to a party and I was supposed
to be on set but I didn't I thought I
was off that day and my assistant was
like
I think you're on camera and I'm like no
I don't think I am and they were like no
I think I think you are and I showed up
too sad just cuz I was like all right
I'll just whatever and I'm like oh
you're here yeah get in the wardrobe
that was like my god but I wasn't like
on ride lines when I was on camera and
then they had like a cutaway to me and I
saw myself and I was like God Gollum
what did you just look bloated red face
I just looked a little banged up but I
it wasn't terrible but I noticed you
don't I mean so yeah you just need you
though do you get you don't it's very
hard to use the term alcoholic do you
think there's no doubt you were an
alcoholic or is it just you know I'm the
guy who likes to drink but I could stop
but I could do this or do you just say
now I'm a [ __ ] alcoholic yeah that's
a common question and I feel like there
are different levels of it so I would
say and I'm an alcoholic to a degree
because I can still I mean I just quit
cold turkey and I go to bars almost
every day and I hang out I go all the
time
and I have no desire to drink
I don't none this time it's different
than the others yeah I don't like flip
out I never like flipped out I just
would be like oh I've got time off you
know I mean I'd be like oh I'm gonna
drink so other people might say you know
I've got a few days off I might go
golfing you know I might hit golf I've
done everything I think was better
tricky was just fun I just really liked
doing it and then the thing about it is
that you get to thing where I would
drink a lot and then the next day you're
really banged up and then I'd be like
okay I got to even out and then you
would have a couple drinks a Bloody Mary
whatever and then eat and then whatever
and go to it have some more drinks or
you know it would revolve around sports
would revolve around a lot of stuff but
the more you do it in a row the more you
have to do it to get even you know what
I mean so I would just get in these ruts
where I was like okay I need a couple
drinks and then I would have a couple
and then it would always I would just
keep going you know there was always
something to build it around you know
and then sometimes I just liked day
drinking and watching a baseball game
you know football game or if the Vikings
or the Twins baseball games on every day
football Sunday is like kind of
everybody it's like outside a but yeah I
would just and I I don't know I really
enjoyed it but is there something
usually when I like if I go out let's
say I go out for some drinks or if I get
to in the past especially because I'm a
big drinker now like I'll have a few
drinks I mean that guy could do that but
there were those times I always made bad
decisions always why did I go home with
that girl
why did I do that why did I whatever it
was and that always made me go you know
I don't wanna drink for a while and
that's I think what everybody does is
were like oh we made a bad decision so
let's stop for a while and until we get
drunk again and make another badge then
I'll stop so did you did you like stop
four months ago because of a bad
decision No so four months ago I was in
the hospital so I was hospitalized I
drank the entire summer by choice really
heavily so I was like you know what I'd
pitch the TV show in the spring they
didn't get it and I was like talking to
my other creator and I'm like I'll just
pay for this on my own I'll just pay for
the pilot and he was like okay and he
kind of flaked out a little bit and then
I was just really frustrated and I had
this summer off so I was like you know
what I'm just tired of the business I'm
tired of so much [ __ ] I'm just gonna get
drunk everyday I didn't have to film I
didn't have to do anything I had a
handful of shows and I was like I'm just
gonna drink no stand up yeah stand up
shows right and so I just did that I
just drank and then the curveball which
just happens with people that my
sister-in-law died pretty unexpectedly
and then another friend died and then
two friends committed suicide and that's
a real wrench you know what I mean which
is an understatement this will happen
all before or endure enduring what Brody
Stephens killed himself beginning of the
year and then my friend mark killed
himself and that manifested even harder
cuz when Brody had taken his life I was
sober and filming and I it was awful but
I didn't really like drinking lose it
you know I didn't turn to the bottle and
then when I drank over the summer with
all that death around me and then Brody
Singh hit again it was
at an eye of the storm you know and
that's where you don't want to go with
if you're drinking or drinking a lot you
know sometimes it's cathartic where you
just want to numb yourself but there's a
balance that you have to find where you
know then it gets dangerous and I went
to that territory where I was drinking
really heavy and not again mine side
well I remember just like I never see on
Facebook I've ever seen Instagram
Twitter like he's always funny [ __ ]
you're stoned funny [ __ ] out there
wisecracks doing this everybody's
laughing but then I see I noticed it
wasn't just one but there's like I'm
heartbroken blah blah if you or someone
you know suffering from this please get
help
blah blah blah I love you or that whoa
but there were there were a few there
weren't like if there was one then there
was another yeah I was like wow what the
[ __ ] warty like you know he's got
people around and then he really loved
and admired dying and you mix alcohol
with that and stuff and now you're
feeling it when you say you were feeling
down was it just like [ __ ] it I don't
wanna be here either I want to be with
them no it wasn't like that
it was just the kind of thing where a
what could I have done my friend Mark
who drank himself to death
had been battling it for a while and I
tried to help him through it and he
would hit me up and he's like hey man I
can't stop drinking and he goes I've
dialed it down I've scaled it back to
beer I've done this and I go you need
you need a detox mark he was living in
Florida and I was in LA and I go you
need an assisted detox you need to find
somebody you know because you should not
it's really a dice roll and I've done it
before when you go cold turkey like that
it depends on how much you drink but I
mean me and Mark [ __ ] drank for those
of you listening I was drinking easily
about a half of vodka a day a fifth
yeah and that's easily and Mark was at
that level and it's you know if you
decide to like you need to take help her
break or whatever you you really need
somebody to monitor the halter Kyodai
you can go yeah you can die I've been to
detox before and they were like alcohol
and they said xanax for the two
first come downs on the planet they said
those are really really shocking nurses
know that one yeah so it's like those
are really intense anyway you know it
just it was just hard it's a numark
battled with it you know and it was I
got the text that he passed and I just
couldn't I just lost it and I you know
then I just drank and you know I I don't
know I was already on I was already
drinking so much you know I I just
couldn't I just decided to drink through
it well you just start to feel like you
know [ __ ] I should have spent more time
with him I should have talked to him
through I should have done that I should
always should have right yeah I mean I
did what I could there wasn't you know I
had another friend and I'd reached out
to him cuz he lived by him you know and
you know we were just heartbroken cuz we
all had battled with it you know and it
was just it was just really rough that
one really like hit me who's lose the
one guy out of all your friends whether
I don't know Sandler or it's like you
have a lot of famous friends you got a
lot of friends that aren't famous you
mix and match whoever you like you like
to be around that's it right you have
those friends who are those friends that
will go Nick you're gonna [ __ ] die I
don't want to see it I love you you're
drinking too much and really level it I
mean has anybody intervened or said
something or really yeah people have all
yeah people have all the time but the
thing is and this is really important to
is people can say all they want you know
what I mean
but if you're drinking you really have
to make that choice yourself and
sometimes it's not your choice with me I
would have wake-up calls and wake-up
calls and then I'm in the hospital and I
have a 10% chance of living go there for
a second so well let me finish my
thought so it really is you know people
just kind of realize ok Nick's gonna
just do whatever the [ __ ] he wants look
you can sit there and go hey don't you
know don't you love a bobble and I you
know I knew all of that it wasn't it
wasn't giving me an epiphany of like oh
right I should [ __ ] you know I was
like ya know I know you know and I
wasn't drinking alone I wasn't you know
there I wasn't like drinking in the dark
like I you know I was going out and
having
and so people were kind of touring so
it's like well it's having a blast he's
hilarious you know so it was like it was
just a really great area but so today to
have me end up in the hospital I just
had hit a wall and I had I went on this
summer bender and it bled into the fall
now we're in September and I am in my
hotel in Minneapolis and I start
throwing up bile all over the place
which is not uncommon
are you drunk at this point no I'm what
just woke up and I'm throwing up by all
I'm like oh and I feel a pain in my body
and my assistant picks me up to go to
the airport and I'm like hey I think
something's wrong and he goes no you're
just hungover dude and I'm like no no I
know what a hangover is you know what I
mean so we get to the airport I go to
the computer to get my ticket I throw up
in the trash can then I go to the bar
get a drink so I could drink through it
throw that up I'm like [ __ ] now the pain
is like on fire in my body so I get on
the plane throw up in the plane in the
bathroom then I'm sitting at window seat
and I have to puke again the planes
about to Lance you can't get up so I
just like open my carry-on and just do a
little side vomit and my carry-on and
the guy next to me it's not this laptop
and he just I know he sees me doing and
he's just like so he doesn't look at me
so I just barf and then I get off the
plane and now it's really painful so
again I got his drink through except as
always I was always like there's always
if you know this is a drinker with your
anxiety or anything you feel like [ __ ]
you always get to a point and me and my
friends call the like the magic cocktail
where it's like drink three or four
we're like oh finally where your nerves
and everything finally everything hits a
plateau like ah all right I'm back and
so I couldn't find that I kept vomiting
so I called my agent and I'm like dude
I've got a I've got to go to the urgent
care like this is like bad and he's like
really and he's been my agent for 20
years so I go yeah so this is like a
funny part his life's funny I pull up
urgent care by the Denver Airport
and I found one that was like mile away
I'm like okay great then I notice that
add one star I was like all right here
gets ranked on stars well first of all
I'm like okay clearly they're not urgent
about caring they have one star I'm like
am I gonna go in and be like yeah I
think I drank too much and they walk out
with like a sex change
I'm like no I have a [ __ ] now no I just
said I have a drinking problem
it's just emergency here so I go to the
urgent Karen and the woman goes oh my
god you need an ambulance and I was like
what and she was like yes they call
paramedics why did she think that she
just I don't know are you green I don't
know what I look like I've no idea fine
I have no idea I was just like no I'm
just hungover and she was like no no no
so the paramedics came and the guy looks
mean he's like whoa he goes what's your
name going through all this stuff and I
answered everything and my hands are
shaking and I go I just have been
drinking a lab of a lot and the guy goes
no I've been on Skid Row for 30 years
he's like you need to go to the [ __ ]
ER and I'm like really and he's like
yeah and then the other guy goes Ryu and
grandmas boy and I was like yeah yeah
yeah that's not let's save that this is
more important important so I go to the
ER and I was there for three weeks this
is how bad it was um are you [ __ ] by
the way you nervous as hell that they're
telling you all these things like what
are they seeing that I'm not seeing
other than I am throwing up when I was
in the ambulance I started to kind of go
holy [ __ ] how did I get myself here you
know what I mean I was like I can't
believe it got to this point and we go
to the ER and they hook me up with
morphine and then I was fine and then my
two opening acts um like found me
somehow through my phone I must have
texted them I did when I landed and then
I check something I was going to ER and
so they found me and they showed up and
then who found you my openers some of
the two comedians that were there I was
in Denver for a gig and the rest it was
just put me on morphine and then it was
flashes and then out completely lights
out for a week and a half that I came to
and then it was just building just
building myself back up and it was like
I mean I've been to I've been through a
lot of things I've been to the ER
got on IVs and I'm fine but this was
just way different so then I you know I
was really East and it was kind it was a
miracle truly a miracle truly a miracle
that you lived they the nurse goes you
should have died she goes what you had
and what you were your body was going
through she's like I swear to god you
she you shouldn't be alive it's crazy
that you're alive and it's from alcohol
it was a perfect storm of pancreatitis
pneumonia blood bacteria alcohol
poisoning altitude sickness so five of
those things hit my system at once five
and she goes you know you can die from
one of those and all five hit your
system at once and she was like it's
like she goes I can't believe you're
walking out of here she goes people come
in for quadruple bypass surgeries and
they're out in like three to four days
four quadruple bypass heart surgeries
another for four weeks three weeks as I
almost remember the names of your nurses
yeah janae yeah I have there yeah I was
like if you guys want to come to the
show they probably know you more than
anybody knows you after these three
weeks oh it was nuts
it's embarrassing were you I mean they
told me what I was doing and I was like
what like what what were you doing oh I
mean I was just rocketing diarrhea I was
I was a hallucination like that's easy
so I was like my family flies in and I
go hey what's going on and they're like
hey and I go and this is real I'm not
joking I go God why did you guys bring
all these rabbits and my sisters like
why didn't I go that's why would you
bring all these rabbits that's like
really nice but I mean it's a lot and
she was like there are no rabbits and I
was like okay I never stuff like that my
nerves got a bless her soul she is still
alive but God bless her she broke up a
fight between me an invisible man there
was like some guy I thought was talking
[ __ ] to me and she had like she was like
there's nobody there it was like Oh from
morphine all the [ __ ] you were on it was
just everything and she goes if you
weren't in altitude and you didn't get
on that plane if you'd stayed in
Minneapolis it would not
as bad like at all like the altitude in
the plane kicked everything intent fold
are you glad it happened in a way I know
it sounds stupid yeah of course I mean I
am glad it happened and it's weird
because it's like a switch just kind of
flips you know where it was like oh like
I'm definitely that I mean the same
person but it you definitely have a
different mindset of course you know
yeah I was it was not stood but you know
you just you live and you learn and I
don't look back on my life and you know
it's just regrets and stuff like oh I
should [ __ ] move god I just look back
I'm like alright well here I am and that
was part of my existence you know didn't
nobody visit you or yeah of course
besides you're the bunnies in the family
yeah a couple more bunnies came by and
then a deer and then a deer um yeah I
know friends came by it was really sweet
but they didn't want to get it all all
of it out there so they you know only
handful of people really knew do you
ever have this feeling of like [ __ ] man
I've been drinking my whole life on and
off but a lot of drinking I like it I'm
a good drunk I have fun all these things
and I get a lot of material and I'm
drunk and then I write [ __ ] down and now
were you scared that oh now I'm gonna be
boring no cuz I'm not boring I know but
you might think oh [ __ ] now I'm not
drinking anymore yeah no that's a valid
question I mean I was kind of over that
stuff anyway cuz it was just like I
didn't want to keep talking about
drinking you know and I was looking at
my stuff and I'm like oh it's a lot of
drinking material which was fun you know
what I mean but after a while I'm like
okay I did that it's just like anybody
if you talk about myself I read books
they're still funny they're still funny
and iced I have some new alcohol jokes
and it's not like from experience but
I'm not one of those people that's now
gonna be you know picky about being
sober and stuff like that not that
that's bad but it's just not my style
and I just don't regret it I had a blast
I mean I had so many story I had so many
stories I mean it was ridiculous stories
I know
I was running around the country I mean
I was you know people like job don't you
regret anything and I'm like no I don't
look look back and go like I wish I got
drunk in San Diego like every city I was
like lit it out of blast well you know I
might do it jagerbomb and I'm 60 I don't
know okay let's just put that down so I
that knee diarrhea diarrhea you know
there's a joke about you know now being
like the sober guy like the sober guy
driving through a drive-thru I remember
that joke how old is that joke where
you're like oh no yeah that's one of my
favorites yeah I closed I think my my
special called taste it and that's one
of my favorites about being the sober
driver and everyone in your car is
shit-faced and you have to go through a
fast-food drive-through and get them
food so you don't order so you're just
fielding orders for everybody that's
hammered yeah that's one of my favorite
I still tell that just I love nostalgia
what do you want I could just yeah is
every job different for you when you
tell it do you always sort of improvise
like you know the joke but you're gonna
add this maybe a different effect yeah
I'll add her to switch it up I mean if
you see me live I sometimes I'll do
older mature if somebody yells something
out I'll do it but for the most part I
always try to do a new act when I tour
for sure you know but everyone some
others jokes that I like doing and
sometimes people like I said she was
great you did a couple of old things and
I'm like yeah cuz I like them yeah and
it's my show
I mean obviously like I always like try
to do as much new stuff but you know
it's like a band that's like yeah saw
you perform stairway to heaven it's an
old one Led Zeppelin take yeah what the
[ __ ] I don't know it's fun you know I
think also there's a stigma sort of what
I'm just thinking about like when people
like you that are your friends do you
get upset with them when they are like
what people are like
hey you know maybe stop drinking or you
like [ __ ] down I'm not gonna hang out
with them anymore they're boring did you
feel like you only needed people who
were kind of called you out no I was
never like that I was just [ __ ] chill
as [ __ ] I was like I always say like I
wish I would just do whatever I wanted
and
people were on board a cool but if
people were worried about me I was never
like [ __ ] you you know I was never like
that
it was funny when people would judge me
sometimes where they'd be like you know
you're a [ __ ] mess I'm gonna say that
well I mean I'm not gonna say names but
does it rhyme with fade no no no
sometimes you but no but some people
would be like hey you're a [ __ ] mess
I'd be like okay you're on your second
divorce and you owe me like 50 grand
like get your [ __ ] together and freeze
to come at me Judge Judy [ __ ] dork
[ __ ] you
so sometimes I would like Sam but for
the most part I always like if people
cared it always meant something to me it
was never dismiss the one did Sam there
ever say anything and was he ever will
see the one you come across always he
was always concerned for sure like what
would he say to you yeah no no you like
hey man like you know you want dial it
down a little bit you know just you know
he would definitely be worried but you
know I you know I would always take it
me like okay but at the end of the day
I'm living my life you know what I mean
I'm going through my stuff I don't like
people judging what I'm going through
and my process I mean granted it for
somebody who's really close to you you
know it's it's hard to see something
like drink that much but I wouldn't get
like smashed around him I wouldn't you
know my family and stuff like that I
would never I'm certain people you
wouldn't go there yeah I wouldn't you
know I wasn't that reckless like it if I
was gonna get reckless I you know I
would be with people that you know like
to drink a lot or it would be an
occasion or something but for the most
part I wouldn't drag anybody through it
like I wouldn't show up and barf on a
Christmas tree you know what I mean so I
kept it together was there anybody
though in your family that honestly it
was almost like I think this could be
almost like a funny show or something
where it's the one guy who was just in
the dark or maybe your mom or sisters
like Nick drinks
you know what just didn't know that side
about you I'm trying to think I don't
think so
I mean one person who's just oblivious
Nick why are you here I honestly can't
name one my first album was called party
when I was 23 right but no I again it
was funny because if I was on one it was
a blast
so I remember this happened several
times well I did a gig in Miami and I
did one show and then I went back to my
hotel and started drinking and my buddy
was opening up for me one of my best
friends and we started drinking and we
drank the next day we drank the next day
I mean it then we had a flight and I'm
like let's just stay and he's like all
right I'm like I'll cover it so we just
stayed in Miami just drank on the beach
how long what this more to the story my
understand yeah you're getting you've
got a DD I cut it out yeah that's
inappropriate inappropriate um
so we kept drinking and then in like a
week goes by and he's like are we
leaving and I'm like yeah just couple
more days couple more days comer knows
another week couple more days and he
goes and we're having a blast here it
was so fun we're meeting people at the
hotel hotel drinking an airport drinking
it to my favorites but hotel I'm just
meeting people from out of town there
for a conference you know I mean we're
just everyone's just ham town it was
[ __ ] a blast and so weeks go by and
he goes hey I've got to [ __ ] go home
and I go what I go we can still he's
like you can but I goes I've got like a
job I've got it you know like I can't
and so I was like all right so I like
flew him home and stuff and I just
stayed for two more weeks so I was there
for over a month how much money did you
spend I don't even know but I just had a
blast
and I just stayed from alone just didn't
meet anybody know I would just meet
people I don't hang out with like a
bartender windows yeah but it was so fun
I just have like a lot of fun of people
of drank with me I just have this fun
you know somebody recognized back are
you next word something like yeah like
I'm a big fan of my cool like you might
do a shot I'm like yeah and then we were
just hanging out now what do you do what
now what do you do do you still go to
bars yeah I go to bars all the time
you're not gonna be tempted there's
nothing that could tempt you now let's
get a shot no because this is something
that somebody told me where and first of
all I'm not tempted I I just I've been
there done that you know what I mean but
someone's like you know if you do want
to drink hat think about having a drink
and then having another one and then
you'll feel good then you'll have
another one then you'll have another one
and then you'll probably have a couple
more and the next day you're gonna wake
up and feel like [ __ ] and you're gonna
have a headache and you'll talk a little
bit of water but then you'll be like
okay I'll have a couple more you know
and then it just goes into a cycle and
I'm like okay yeah that's what would
probably happen
I wasn't like great at drinking like one
day and then stopping I think it has to
do with probably I mean maybe not with
you but it's got to be self-loathing
like I have no control or I keep doing I
know it's fun but why can't I just stop
this why do I need this why do I need
you know that make ever be the you know
cuz I've suffered from this like being
the center of attention make everybody
laugh I got to please everybody ever
he's gonna have fun
I I don't care about me as long as
everybody's having fun and when does
that stop you're like you know what I
yeah you know I just I don't I can't do
that anymore I gotta try to do it
without this so that's the new chapter I
guess not really not for me I was never
like I've got to be the life of the
party I was like hey I've ever parties
and we want to come over hey what's up
then we were just hanging I was never
that kind of guy and I and for the most
part I never drank when I filmed like
staunchly I mean it you know a couple
times I would but for the most part I
was I've got a movie coming out in May
with me and David Spade we shot in
Hawaii and I didn't drink at all and
people would drink on the weekends
people would drink all the time and
they're like hey you went drank and I'm
like now I just you know people like how
do you do that I'm like I don't I don't
want to it was really all about what I
wanted to do if I wanted a drink I would
drink what do you want to do now I mean
now I'm just like excited about work I'm
wrote a TV show I'm shooting a pilot
episode that I'm funding myself in April
putting that together now it's amazing
and I'm doing stand-up and bring a new
special I'm talking about developing a
movie with the director of Grandma's Boy
and I'm just you're just all work
Nick yeah Goosen oh yeah Nick Oh sad huh
what you can finish the last my name is
Nick - Nick yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's true I looked at my god Nick and
you're like yeah Mike no it's like yeah
oh but even like another movie I have
coming on man
me and Josh Tim al Libi aman -
everything before you do have it so
ordered
with who what movie you airplane mode
what are you talking you have Tourette's
in a real I don't know you're talking
cuz now I have the wrong Missy and buddy
games are coming out in May and even
tomorrow who is directing the movie like
everybody was having cocktails on the
weekends and Josh was like having
cocktails he's like how do you you're
just not drinking and I'm like now I
just and you know I just don't want him
I don't know I've already said that but
I don't think that's cool either when
your friends around you're like going to
it
it should not nobody should be going hey
man you can't drink really come on I get
one no people don't do that it's in
[ __ ] high school or it's like no it's
like oh you're really not drinking
people just expect me to drink so
they're like oh you're not and I'm like
no and I'm like alright that's cotton
the same thing the way you said it
because they're just well no they're
just surprised as they should be people
don't know that I don't drink when I
film for the most part and so there they
were just surprised like oh Nick
swardson's not having a drink and
they're like alright but nobody was like
dude [ __ ] such a [ __ ] no nobody did
that to me you play one of these
characters in a movie yeah that'll be my
next one [ __ ] lip a musical dude I mean
you're busy as [ __ ] don't you think
you're more way more productive no I was
always productive I've created a show
every year I would write a pilot that
was one thing that was driving me nuts
is I would create a show and I would
have to be amazing and be really funny
me not great produce there's all these
people and it would go nowhere and so
the people out there that go like oh
what's that guy doing what's that guy up
to how come that guy doesn't work it's
like you don't understand behind the
scenes a lot of people are like busting
their ass
trying to get [ __ ] going and you create
stuff and then the networks like I don't
get it what is that now we're good what
about that script yeah all the time I
expect me read that you wrote with Danny
McBride that I did table read we thought
we were gonna start filming that yeah we
did a basically a Grandma's Boy type
show which was a video game office
comedy which is so funny Danny McBride
was producing it for those of you out
there this is a script I wrote with Nick
who senior director grandma's boy
Michael was gonna be cast Danny McBride
was gonna produce and it was [ __ ]
hilarious it was called game on Efrain
from Napoleon Dynamite it was gonna be
an end you know with everything and they
were like and now we were like Wyatt and
the past on it so it's like even with
all those elements even back in the day
I did I wrote the show gay robot it was
on Comedy Central they bought it Adam
Sandler's producing it we filmed a pilot
let's see you can find on YouTube and
coming so I was like now and I was like
what what's happening the thinking of
all the people that that happens to how
many hours how many hours have you I
wouldn't call it wasted but put into
something and all these projects and
nothing ever happened with them people
just gotta get it like I got it he gets
it Danny McBride gets it Adam Sandler
gets it and it's just like stuff like
that after a while you're just like
cocktails yeah well you know I think
people do that all the time with food
and my dad still doesn't you know for
him it's like yeah well what are you
doing it's like well I don't know I've
worked hard as I could to write three
things in the last years that no one
bought or someone bought and then we
didn't make after four months of
negotiations I spent three years busting
my ass for nothing they don't see any of
that if it you're either on the TV yeah
you're not on the TV
yeah you're not working well that's why
stand-ups great and I always write and
develop that because it's my control I
do what I love my fans are awesome you
have a new special yeah I'm getting
ready for that this year what's called I
can't announce I've got like all the
artwork and stuff I want to save that
it's really it's really I'm really
friggin filming I don't know yet I'm
there's still a lot up in the air where
I'm filming
and where it's gonna be on but um it's
coming out it's already coming together
really well how much time do you put in
to your sat like you have to have like
an hour right an hour to do a special
for the most part you want an hour it
depends upon what format it's on because
sometimes there's half hour it's like a
half hour on Netflix there's an hour on
Netflix there's an hour on Comedy
Central which is actually 42 minutes
there's you know that now there's like
short form options where they're just
showing 10 minute chunks so for the most
part you want a new hour especially if
you're touring and you're doing feeders
and stuffs people are like paying good
money to see like a fresh hour in my
opinion and then however long that takes
to develop an hour I just want to make
sure I'm happy with it and how long does
that happen because you go to the improv
scholars you go to the Laugh Factory and
sunset you travel the comedy so you kind
of do the circuit over and over every
night working on the same [ __ ]
absolutely for the most part yeah you
just want to build on it and do you ever
who's the WoW who's who's the love sorry
it was the one guy that you're like I
really want to know I want his opinion
means something I want to know if he
really thinks this is funny would you
not need that look I know it's why do it
sometimes but I but I know you know I've
done this law I've done this 25 years so
I know I'll think of something like okay
but I mean if the other night I was at
the Comedy Store I was backstage and I
was with Bill burr and Bill's old friend
of mine 20-plus years and we were just
sitting there catching up and I go hey I
tried this bit less I didn't work he
just what is it and I told the biggest
out [ __ ] yeah now didn't [ __ ] work
and I was like no I liked it but I think
I set it up wrong he said how'd you set
up and I can't remember what it was and
in my head I was like oh yeah I set it
up wrong and then just even talking
about it with Bill but it made me feel I
was like it's good right it's funny
right he's like yeah it's a funny bit
bill would have said there's nothing fun
oh yeah he laughs he was like oh yeah so
I you know sometimes it's good to just
go like I'm not crazy right and then I
realize just a technical setup of it I
didn't get into it right sometimes you
overdo a setup where you talk too much
you know like there's just key words
that I was
I need to emphasize that and that cut it
down and then BOOM before the last four
months when you're going like do your
sets they didn't you have a drink I
remember we'd have a drink maybe a drink
maybe two drinks something that you know
take the edge off go up there be relaxed
but now you're not doing that right so
that's what I talked about changing the
war changing like how your probably
doesn't stand up sober I've done it
drunk I've done it yeah I've done it
every kind of way but when I started
stand-up I wasn't shit-faced you know
what I mean right so I spent years and
years where I didn't drink at all I mean
when I first started I never drank at
all really so it wasn't weird to me
where I needed to cut that edge do you
still think there's uh you still hell do
you still have scared me scared Ryan
yeah do you still get nervous do you
still bomb do you still go [ __ ] I ate it
do you still how do you rebound how does
that work you don't really bomb because
I've done this long enough where you
don't really bomb how do you not bomb
because you're just that good you've
been doing so long that you just think I
just I don't know yeah I know how to get
out of it I mean usually I just know
what I'm doing so even if something
doesn't work I'm like alright I'll try
this or I'll try that I you know it's
not it's never like what I say like all
the time it's never but I but like when
I bombed for the first time back in New
York I what year was that
Oh 1998 I just tanked because I had you
need confidence and I was still nervous
and so when it started to bomb I was
like I got booed off like whoa yeah boo
it was in New York so I cut my teeth
there I thank God so when I started
Minnesota was like all right yeah yeah
everything that's so hard to bounce or
so plate and is is it hard to get back
onstage ft balmy it's really hard when
you're that young and that new it is
jarring so I was going up multiple times
a night and then when that happened I
took like five days off or I was
shell-shocked could you have actually
gone in the other direction say I'm done
no you just get you get addicted to
doing stand-up like once you once you do
it you can't do anything else it's not
something that when people always ask me
like how do I
I want to get into it I want to do this
it's like okay well be prepared to eat
[ __ ]
well beep ready to light bomb be
prepared to go through a rollercoaster
of you know it looks easy and it's
really not so it's like I'm always
really honest with people it's really
hard when I started you know it's a
little easier Knox you've got social
media and you've got the internet and
stuff like that so you can post ups on
YouTube you can post up on your
Instagram you can do all that stuff I
mean when I started it was like you were
doing the road you were getting in your
car driving to a bar in butt [ __ ]
nowhere for a hundred bucks slappers no
not even less than flapper now it would
be like Gary's basement Jamboree and
then you were in some [ __ ] basement
Gary's got a [ __ ] paintball gun
pointed at your [ __ ] [ __ ] god no but
you know you would travel around and if
you ate [ __ ] you just had to tough it
out
it was now there's nothing you could do
there were barely even cell phones then
so yeah it was it was tough dude I mean
I'm sleeping in my car I was sleeping
anywhere I could Steven bushes
come on yeah no one sleeps in a bush I
slept in a bush that's the story I've
told before bush yeah no I was in San
Francisco and I drove from Minnesota and
my car broke down and I slept in my car
then my car got towed
and then I would bounce around I didn't
really know any comics but I bounced
around on couches and I'm finally they
were just kind of like all right in my
car I could I couldn't afford to fly
home so I just walked into a park and I
was like I heard sleep here and it slept
in a park it was [ __ ] Wow
yeah I mean I was like 19 so you don't
give a [ __ ] yeah I had a fake ID so just
get drunk and pass out who's the one guy
that you really think is just [ __ ]
funny like somebody new that you're like
or in the last couple years you're like
that guy makes me laugh or that woman
makes me laugh a lot I don't know what
it is there's just the delivery that's
something special cuz you don't seem
like a guy that cracks up from other
people [ __ ] a lot you're probably doing
your own thing you've heard it all in a
way whose delivery it's rare when you
really laugh at something it's really
hard because I you've watched so much
comedy
and it pisses people off in social
situations sure so what if it was like a
group people and somebody said something
that ruins laughing and in my head I'm
like oh that's funny but I don't like
laugh and then they're like oh oh sorry
sorry I'm not professional comedian that
wasn't funny enough for you and I'm like
oh no it was funny like oh yeah you
didn't laugh and I'm like yeah I don't
I'm I don't laugh anymore yeah I don't
I've done I'm done laughing well our
buddy Harlan Williams has a heat way at
a manager died but Harlan I guess he'd
heard everything he wasn't being
addicted Harlan pitch yes so he's
pitching him something he's like yeah so
anyway at the end the guy [ __ ] falls
down a [ __ ] hole and breaks his ankles
like hey times up God and he pitches
this pitch and the guy his manager looks
um goes I'm on the floor and Harlan goes
I don't get it you don't think it's
funny he's like I'm on the floor Harlan
I thought it was funny
I'm on the floor he just didn't laugh
the guy just didn't laugh for whatever
reason straight-faced I'm on the floor
oh my god it's kind of like you would
like that that was fine no no I thought
was fine I just didn't laugh yeah but
I'll think something's brilliant I'll
watch stuff from my god it's really so
who is it I mean I don't really keep up
with it because I don't watch comedy so
it's like I don't set out to watch
stand-up you know I I really just can't
watch it the last thing I watch was
chappal sticks and stones and you know I
thought I thought I loved it I was
amazing and you know there's guys that
are there's people women yeah this
people are funny of course this is
especially hard not to laugh at you're
like obviously you love saying you left
Spade you love all these guys it's night
or that you do it right so is it hard to
like do you still think they're funny
when they're on stage do you still think
they're jokes are funny or like no I'll
still laugh yeah for sure
like what's the one thing the Spade does
it because he's gimmicky whatever it is
that you go there he has things that
always make me laugh what is it I'm not
gonna like point out Spade stuff but
what's the one thing like that Spade
does that the one thing that he's that
gets you I like um and I have always
like this I like asides
when something's not planned and they
comment on how what the reaction was or
it's something really organic I always
like that in movies too where you can
tell it's not scripted because I
improvise a lot it's like reno911.com
thing that's just clearly and I can tell
if just organically like you know
they'll be like oh uh yeah those kind of
things like those make me laugh I said
like oh somebody somebody just sitting
there a rep in revenue that's it the bed
you know yesterday I poured just even a
line that's organic that's just part of
the the scene where you just clearly
bacon you can tell I would always crack
up on Grandma's Boy
because we would make up so much stuff
and we would do stuff on the fly where I
would throw stuff out at Joel David
Moore who played JP was like the robot
guy and I would always throw stuff out
at him and I couldn't be in any scenes I
would laugh immediately because his
voice was so funny that was one of the
hardest was that was really hard to keep
a straight face and Kevin Nealon and
Bucky Larson there was a scene we could
not get the room it was the apartment
apartment yeah and we couldn't get
through it and people were and any actor
comedian notices if you're in a scene in
your laughing and you get yelled at it
makes it worse because now you're
conscious of it and then now you can't
stop laughing if you're in a scene with
a buddy and reno 9-1-1
the most outlandish stuff i could to get
them to break to make them laugh so I
was always would just wrack my brain for
Terry insanity and it was great that I
would get them to break are you gonna
love to going back there having that
whole reunion thing or whatever cuz
every show is doing it and Reno 911
supposedly so why wouldn't they ask you
back there because would you do it I'm
not going back to Reno noun 1 ok add
they asked me and I thought about it and
I just I love them and I love the show
but I just I spent my time as Terry and
the character had come full circle with
the end up with a movie and everything
and I just it was just something I want
to just move on you know and go forward
and I've developing this new show and uh
uh you know I love Terry but it was just
something it was really a hard choice it
wasn't an easy choice but I'm not coming
back you know what I underst
but you is when you are in like you know
all these shows because I did typical
Rick I did this other show you did I
forgot was called it was called pretend
time pretend time and Nick Swardson
she always invited me to do stuff and I
loved it I love playing with you but
what I do notice on set is as I don't
know lack of a better word like
malleable as you are like you can just
kind of do [ __ ] off-the-cuff there is an
intensity that I don't see in real life
with you right and I noticed other
people notice that are working with you
that's just very like no right we got to
get it done let's go it we got to get
this done let's go come on let's go
like like there's a there's a certain
raps there's just an int
my house porcelain yeah all right you're
just it's it's it's not a bad thing it's
a focus work I want this to be right I
want to do it now I just noticed about
you yeah it's a very control thing with
stand up I'm really controlling of what
I do you know and even though it's loose
and stuff but when you're filming a
movie or anything especially if I've
written it and I my words I just know
how to execute a joke so I will be like
really staunch about something like that
if we're behind schedule I want to keep
it on schedule too for sure but I want
to get it right so I'll know you know I
beg no no no deliver like this no no
you're too hard on that word no no just
say it no throw it away don't put an
emphasis just buh buh buh buh buh you
know so I get and people like oh all
right you're not mad you just show so
mad that's like no this is how you do it
you know yeah like this new pilot is
really great I'm really excited and I'm
finding it out of my own money I'm just
like I'm just gonna shoot this how much
we don't know yet I mean it's gonna
better no it's not like crazy this is a
half-hour kind of ten minutes so it's
like a presentation so for people
watching I can't save the cast yet
because they're not locked down yeah
we're talking to some really great song
I haven't signed my contract yeah you're
playing the elder okay so this is kind
of you're putting your own money out
into this yeah and I'm doing that it's a
director grandmas boy the line producer
who did the movie peanut butter Falcon
which is amazing and I wanted to shoot
on my own because I'm tired of waiting
for people I'm tired of people telling
me what to do what's funny and so I'm
just like I'll just pay for it so we're
shooting it in April and we're really
excited I love it and I just I want all
control of just like this is exactly how
it should be executed when you're just
an actor on a set much laid bet more
laid-back do whatever fun laughs and
doing Everett when you're in control
when you're creator when you're a writer
you're more hey let's go
would you say it I mean I produced a lot
of movies with Sandler and he gives me a
lot of free rein to be like you know
chime in if you have anything but if I'm
just an actor for hire on a movie on
it's fun it's a it's kind of a release
but I'll watch somebody in me like I
don't think II did that right like in my
head right
I'd like that delivery wasn't on that
line should be rich okay because you
were like I mean back in the day was in
a huge movie but you were like really
first of all you weren't drinking at all
not once we're on the set in Indiana
when we fell back in the day back in the
day and when you were working I mean if
that's seen in the car right [ __ ] I
love that sense much well it sounds just
because I'd wreck to the movie but
you're so intense and real and like you
can see the sweat and like the emotion
and I'm like and you were so easy to
[ __ ] work with you it was just like
there were some pains in the asses but
for me you were like what do you want to
do I remember your knees were hurting in
that little [ __ ] car and you're
supposed to be a super having sex with
you no I didn't live pregnant Liz and it
was just like you were just right there
you were it wasn't and that's hard as
much as a first-time director of a
feature and I was like I didn't have
much time but on the other side you just
being an actor awesome it was awesome to
have a pro that's done this right you
know respect other people's time and
energy so what you were going through I
was just like I'm here for you
so whatever you need for me yeah I
thought that like just let me know you
know I'm not gonna hold anything up
I've never had an ego I'm never not even
about that I'm just about to work and
like okay whatever you need for me I'm
here for you so that's really important
how upset were you that Sandler didn't
get a Oscar not for uncut jump honestly
as they did it bother you at all
it's it really bother me I thought he
was great and I thought I've been
awesome if he did but I mean some stuff
like that it's like he it doesn't take
away from what he did you know he but he
was great it's on film forever yeah you
know you don't need that you don't need
that so to me it was kind of like yeah
it was yeah whatever it would have been
awesome but he was great so it's like
nobody takes that away and look I'm not
saying this because I've been anything
other than I watched it and I just
thought of all the performances and I
think wow great oh yeah he was good yeah
that was the one performance that I just
looked at and I go I couldn't I couldn't
imagine doing that I don't know how he
did that yeah he was so [ __ ] quick
the lines just speed of why that was
in different directions that his
characters are going in on the phone
like let him let him in go let him at
dawn to [ __ ] keep him there yeah yeah
well no doctors I wasn't gonna but the
way I was blown away I thought yeah in
fact I was betting on him to probably
win the Oscar or maybe Joaquin because
it was like maybe the movie wasn't
everybody's whatever right in a tense
movie I thought uncut Jim's was hard to
watch
it was [ __ ] intense so intense you
have to watch it once but you're like I
don't know if I could watched it again
because watch it in the theater cuz it
takes you over we're at exits and I was
like dude I had a major anxiety oh my
god
yeah no he was he was great and now the
movie just the whole thing is such an
experience yeah and it's really out of
his wheelhouse I mean it was just like
whoa Garnett that was great that was
fantastic but yeah I mean awards are
just like rama's just happened I don't
want III don't even go on social media
that much but when I checked it and
people are outraged about so-and-so not
winning or sones it it's like you guys I
mean just let let your work just your
work you know people love you and come
on Nick Swardson said my sister just
asked me if I wanted to do an escape
room every room over the holidays with
my family was an escape room so I'm good
it's one of my favorites that Steve's
dad was a tweet I did it was it was it a
tweet I thought maybe it was one of your
lines in his show no it's a tweet I
think yeah it was this is I love my
family sorry that was it was though I
still want you to think about the one
family member that just you drink is the
funny sure tell you one of my favorite
moments my sister's wedding which her
first wedding which was such a hot mess
so I it was in Florida on the beach and
I flew in a couple days early me and my
brother and we started drinking and I
was a tornado I'm in the wedding I'm
about 24 years old and I'm in the
wedding just just to sum it up quickly I
forgot to bring my suit it's white no
suit I was in the wedding party forgot
my suit she's like you know Massoud I'm
like can I borrow one she's like what
go buy one there's no suit store on this
like island so then I I will run down
the street I had written
suck it on my chest and a permanent
marker
I was walking around shirtless the
thought it was super funny and then
that's how I met her in-laws they were
like who the [ __ ] is this sounds I'll
[ __ ] face I'm like this funny not funny
then I missed so the trolleys going to
the wedding and I pass the trolley and a
moped going to the beach as they're
going to the wedding and they're like
Nick what what the [ __ ]
then I was like oh [ __ ] is that today
seriously turned around had to borrow a
suit from somebody that didn't even fit
me so he had an extra suit thank God so
I'm wearing this awkward said I get
fired from being an usher then I go to
that reception yeah she was like no this
is ridiculous I'm just sweating at this
wedding and I'm set smoking and like
[ __ ] reception it was just it was a
hot mess and then so my grandma
I was drinking white Russians at the
time so I was a big lebowski fan so I'm
drinking white Russians and my
grandmother god rest her soul she goes
Nicholas can make me in white Russian
and I go yeah of course and she took a
sip of mine which was strong as [ __ ] and
so I made her one not nearly as strong
she took a sip she goes Nicholas and I
go what and she goes make me one like
yours and I was like oh all right forgot
your Anna a couple words grandma you
know what you're doing so I pour this
stuff on she's like that's right the
dude's name I forgot I had your blood
yeah she was like wife okay guy drinking
longer than you have
I remember all the time growing up
tissues rip Manhattan's and all that
stuff in there like whose wedding was
that by the way my sisters now does your
sister still talk about that wedding is
she still married to the same guy no she
was she's twice divorced twice divorced
twice but um yeah I know she'll bring it
up sometimes but you know do you
remember how you were how many times
have you heard that oh my god yeah when
I went I just went home for the holidays
in Minnesota and I drank a lot better
this summer and I was like
yeah I'm not drinking some people like
oh good it wasn't like and they were
like they weren't like good but they're
like oh yeah you needed a timeout I'm
like why and they're like dude you know
some are gonna be now now it's gonna be
God do you remember how sober you were
last Christmas yeah you were so sober do
you remember that yeah I was sober of
course I remember that yeah
Nick Swartz and this is called
shit-talking with rose and i'm these are
questions from fans real quick my
patrons here good all Jason says what
inspired you to become a comedian and/or
actor quickly could say it um what
inspired me to be a comedian actor it
that really was no inspiration it was I
went to rehab when I was 16 for drugs I
got caught smoking a blunt in high
school in the middle of class and will
during school and then I was arrested
with me and my friends we had
court-ordered rehab so I had to dry out
back then I don't do any drugs anymore
and I took acting to get an easy grade
and I took Peter I was like my GPA was
diarrhea and so I took acting and then
the teacher was like whoa she's like you
have a gift like this isn't just a class
and so she advanced me long story short
I just it took away my addiction I
became addicted to comedy and acting so
that was kind of my weird inspiration
was I just became obsessed with it and
just threw myself into it I threw myself
into everything all this acting all
these plays different theatre companies
improv and started stand-up at a high
school and I just committed my life to
all from one go let's get a free a let's
just do that literally by chance yeah
and then the more research I did the
more I studied acting and comedy and
stand-up and everything and then I then
I became an aficionado and just became
obsessed with it and loved it
Sophie who are the top three comedians
you admire you could take sama off there
cuz or maybe the people you know but who
are the top who are the top comedians I
admire
um can I guess I would say Richard Pryor
don't put names in my mouth all right
this is a question for me you're just a
[ __ ] attention or so weird you
organic I told you if you don't get
enough attention you get over your dying
that's what happens yeah your first
podcast or the [ __ ] micro machine man
so it's a dated reference or a [ __ ]
auctioneer well you were an alkali was
like yeah but I learned to respect to
talking to people well you know I'm just
trying to left him go one up trying to
move things along yeah you're real
steaming now you're made out of [ __ ]
mayonnaise comedian Jude Mayer besides
prior prior um I would say Sandler I
would say that just because of his work
ethic and how he juggles being such a
giant star and a family man and having
such passion for what he does even at
this point it's just been I've had
front-row seats to it working with him
and him being such a great friend I've
seen it so I really admire him not David
Spade um I don't know
I would Pryor for sure anybody that came
out of was able to turn pain into comedy
III admire across the board I mean this
comedian set have gone just threw all
those older comedians that went through
that of just and you know contemporary
to but turning pain in the comedy I
admire across the board of just that's
[ __ ] really hard come his heart alone
but to you know turn the corner like
that at my surprise Danny Murphy wasn't
on there Angie asks will we say
broadened it to a lot of comedians and
I'm just gonna boil it down to three
people well we see a Netflix special
from you this year it might be Netflix
but you'll see it special for me this
year
Andrew C and Raj what is the best back
and forth you have ever had with a
heckler during a stand-up set hecklers
usually you're just hammered and they
they just kinda that's a good question
but I'm trying to think of a great a
great one a lot of them are so in the
moment that you I don't even really
remember them but I remember a lot of
back and for
I swear oh god sorry I'm dropping the
ball in it whoever asked this question
but I can't think of one specifically
come we'll come back to it okay Danny
what single comedy bit has made you
laugh the hardest me or somebody else if
it's somebody else I would say Charlie
Chaplin's a night in the show
it's an old sketch he did a lot of
shorts before he became a huge movie
icon star and he had a short call
tonight in the show and it is still I
was obsessed with Charlie Chaplin I
would watch everything if you really
want to see just pure genius there's not
really in my opinion nobody better
overall on planet earth than Charlie
Chaplin and a night in the show he plays
two characters a performer and the
heckler and it is [ __ ] piss your
pants
I think hilarious because he plays this
drunk heckler and there's a scene where
he has a fire hose and this is back in
the day when there was already really
regulating the fire hose or what the
pressure was like or what was gonna
happen so he I'm not gonna say anything
else but he just reads a fire hose into
the scene and it is chaos ensues and he
still has to hold it together
Lukas M this is serious question so
you'd have to answer this honestly and
be honest will the fart jokes ever end
I don't even know how to answer that I
don't know where my comedy will take me
so I don't think so it's not a conscious
choice but I have a question for you
Lucas well farting ever end I thought
you're gonna say do we need oxygen to
breathe will we always need oxygen the
answers right back to your attention
they will not even in your moment Aran's
shut up god christopher talking over
here is this yes a peppermint chatty
tommy take a while Jerry W favorite
director to work with him why I would
probably I mean it's a given but I'd
probably say Nickerson because I know
it's gonna look I mean I respect to all
my directors but uh goose and I I know
it's gonna look great because he's
really great on a budget like he can
take a five hundred dollar idea a five
thousand dollar idea of Grandma's Boy
which is five million dollars and he can
make it look like a billion dollars
so I I just trust him he trusts me with
the comedy and I trust him with how it's
gonna look Lisa having were Alcon crest
I just tried to get the answer what's
the question am i right
well let's see having worked as a writer
producer an actor and many shows and
movies and also have as a touring
touring
comedian touring which type of work do
you prefer Falcon Crest
Falcon do so if it does kind of fit yeah
Hollywood Life or the Turin Comic Life
um that's a question that people wonder
where it they're so different so a
touring comedian is exhausting
exhilarating crazy again it goes back to
it's great because I have control I'm
the show my fans are awesome it's an
immediate response it's a great bonding
experience it's just fun and Hollywood's
the shooting stuff is great too because
if you're lucky enough to have control
over the dialogue something seeing
something that you wrote and casting it
and seeing people deliver it and execute
it is such a great experience that's
unique unto itself I mean just imagine
writing something that had seeing people
like read your or
and stuff like that it's really trippy
and it's really cool and also being in a
scene with great actors I've been in
scenes with so many people that it's
like it's insane and I'm working with
just a comedy alone Sandler and spade
Scheider and norm and you know blades of
glory 30 minutes or less with Danny
McBride you know well it's just so fun
what's the most you've ever gotten paid
for one night of stand-up for one night
how many people were there and what's
the most you made 500 boxes of Froot
Loops
they brought I'm not gonna see how much
I've gotten P is that rude outside yeah
that's the route which is a terrible
question it's not terrible but it's yeah
you kind of wanted to answer it though
no I have people ask me that questions
what's this in my first interview what's
the lead singer talking did anyone ever
ask you - did anyone not pay you they
owed you money to do stand-up in didn't
pay you know I got threatened to not get
paid so I was late when I was first
starting and I was doing a gig in New
York and I was a little late and this
guy was like really mad and he's like I
don't want to [ __ ] pay you too late
but my wife's cool so I'm gonna pay you
and I'm like all right sorry I was 19
from Minnesota I cried it missed the
train I didn't know what I was doing
he's like I don't [ __ ] care so here's
the money but I don't want to pay you
my wife's cool I'm like tear wave thank
you he's like [ __ ] I don't believe half
of that no that's true actually real he
was really angry yeah he was like really
mad I was and I was a clearly good but
y'all I'm just like just moved in New
York and no trains were but that was the
only time dude I Love You Man this is
honestly I'm super proud I think I mean
it's just awesome that you have your
[ __ ] together that you just you know you
went through a lot and I love seeing you
back on top I love seeing you keeping
busy and the fact that you stopped
drinking stuff hey it's your choice and
it's a health thing and you had a
wake-up call and you don't need it
anymore and that's it yeah it's it is
it's awesome I feel great and for those
of you listening out there it really is
you have to make the choice you have to
really want to do it you know what I
mean you have to go like okay enough is
enough and you're going to hit a wall
you know what I mean it's that's one of
the things if you're a drinker drinker
like I was a drinker drinker I mean
serious a lot of my friends were too and
it's you're physically going to hit a
wall and it [ __ ] sucks I mean being
in the ER it was I remember it was just
hell on earth tubes everywhere it was so
much pain it was just non-stop taking
blood monitors just everything and it
was just I was like oh my god and I had
had a blast up and tell then you know so
just so you know just if you need
however you want to do it what your
process is but you know just know that
just you have to make that choice and if
you need help just you know just ask
somebody you know reach out and people
will help you you know I'm not gonna get
preachy but no you don't have to I think
it's people hearing you say that and
you've gone you've gone through it
you've seen friends God you just I've
been there done that yeah and it's like
you know I don't know where I am
yeah what what do you want I did I had
something else was gonna ask you can't
remember it it's my real name Gary was
that the question no I feel like it was
for those
wondering about the new show I'm working
on it's called boo and it's about two
sons of a world-famous ghost hunter that
don't have their [ __ ] together and they
can't until they confront their own
demons they can't be as good as their
dad and it's a it's like the contouring
meets step Robert I love that actual
thing I mean it's amazing the conjuring
meets step wrong I know I was gonna say
a lot of comedians you always hear
comedian's hate themselves they just say
they do drugs they all you know they
died all you hear all the horrible
things it's the worst thing you have to
really hate yourself to be a stand-up
comedian these things do you look in the
mirror you someone who honestly can say
I love you Nick or I like you Nick or
Nick I'm working on it that's such a
therapy question well I think it's I
think it's an honest question he's so
corny Weaver right now I'm supportive I
think it's important I mean I'd be like
sup so today what do you like yourself
yeah I do
yeah I do that's really all the question
oh but you just we could just use that
did you like it you like yourself but I
like myself you love yourself sure
that's been dude I don't think a lot of
people do yeah I mean it's a weighted
question I mean sometimes if I rip some
beef I don't look I just went right to a
fart joke yeah I do love myself and I do
like myself sometimes I'm like yeah all
right guy yeah I hits fair I think
that's more like hey I like myself
sometimes and sometimes I might thought
man how do you gotta get better than
that dude you'd be better now yeah you'd
be better than that man do you wanna all
right I'm gonna get you out of here I'll
take some pictures with a thanks for
allow me to be inside of you of course
thank you for allowing me to be and say
Nick say a lot of the fans they might
guys say slaughter let's see me blabber
about yeah it's awesome
take care
well how about that two guests in a row
that both went to a Wellness Center and
something I can relate to because I went
and it both helped them out tremendously
and these are guys that you know I'm not
going oh well as I'm not people are
always too good for everything that you
know they I think it's just when you
when you can be vulnerable when you can
just say this is what I'm this is how
I'm feeling I don't care what people
think this is me I am a mess I'm a
beautiful mess I think there's an
awesomeness to that where people can
will they embrace it look at Robert
Downey jr. got him has there ever been
anyone a bigger mess than him and now a
bigger star because somehow people were
just like god I wish that guy would get
his [ __ ] together like even chance after
chance after chance I mean this guy was
just blowing it and they saw him back on
top I'm not saying that that's the way
to go him just saying it when you're
vulnerable although I think he was just
getting caught doing stupid [ __ ] and how
vulnerable he was anyway and now let's
give a shout out to my top-tier patrons
you guys on patreon are so wonderful and
let me give you your shoutout I've
messaged each and every one of you
you've all got messages from me it's me
you know it's me the way I talk how can
anybody else talk like that
Allison L Andrew see Angelina gbeary I
Bob be bullet X Bryan H Chris cjp Deon K
Emily F Emily s Hamza be Jason D Jason W
Jennifer as [ __ ] Jerry w GL e Joshua D
Kevin R Kimberly Lauren G Leah s Lee
mark a Melissa are Michael s Nancy D
neil w you newcomer you Niko P I love
you I love Zach I love your family
you're amazing you know this I just
talked to you thank you for the help on
the you know what Raj I love you Raj
Robert be my man rocks raccoon your new
your name rocks raccoon samantha em
Sarah V Sean V Stacey be tiene Tricia
Vanessa in the sky and you Kegel
[Music]
thanks for all the support make sure you
follow us our handle inside of you ad
inside a podcast at inside of you pod on
Instagram and Twitter
follow us on Facebook I'm doing the
Instagram live folks the Facebook lives
trying to entertain you while you
entertain me I love talking to you join
patreon if you're so inclined help the
show out help a charity more importantly
in Ronald McDonald House echoes of hope
for foster youth food on foot or I'm a
part of it club member tell my Sencha
there's a lot of love in this world
don't forget it you're loved we're all
loved we've got a groovy kind of love
thank you for allowing to be inside you
thank you I hope you enjoyed today's
episode with Nick Swardson and that's
about it I did it by myself
[Music]